having questioned and scrutinized the 26  nominees for ursula Fonda Lions team MEP  s will vote on whether to approve or  reject the new European Commission  having got an additional 850 million  euros from EU governments to better fund  climate action research small businesses  and young people Parliament will vote on  the EU 2020 budget MEP s will debate the  --use goals ahead of the cop 25 climate  summit in Madrid they want the EU to  commit to net zero co2 emissions by 2050  the winner of the 2018 Sakharov Prize  for freedom of thought Alex cents off  will be in Strasbourg to collect the  prize following his release from jail in  Siberia the filmmaker was arrested and  imprisoned after protesting Russia's  annexation of Crimea parliament  president David sassily will announce  the winner of the 2019 Lux film prize  the three finalists are cold case  hammered hold by Matt Berger God exists  her name is petronia by tiana meet  obscure and the realm by Rodriguez or a  [ __ ]  [Music]